One of the storylines that still kind of being
written about Republicans in the 21st century
is
whether or not Donald Trump's election in
2016 represents the beginning of a major multi-decade
downfall for the Republican party in the United
States or not. And we don't know the answer
yet. The 2020 elections going to be a big
part of it, but we already have some data
points. We already had Democrats taking over
control of the house back in 2018 in the midterms
by one of the larger margins in recent midterms.
Anecdotally because they ran, you know, the
serial sex assault or Roy Moore in Alabama,
Democrats took a Senate seat in Alabama, although
it's likely that they're going to give that
back in the 2020 election. But then at the
state level, there have been some pretty major
advancements and last night there were a bunch
of statewide elections and Republicans got
absolutely crushed in some key places. And
it could be, I mean, we don't know, but it
could be a sign about what could happen in
2020 if we're ready to work.
It always assumes that we're ready to work.
So let's go through some of these. Kentucky.
Kentucky is a very red state. Uh, Donald Trump
won by 30 points over Hillary Clinton in 2016
in Kentucky, a Kentucky had a Trump loving
governor named Matt Bevin, a major democratic
party. Victory has taken place in Kentucky,
the democratic challenger, Andy Bashir, who
was his, I guess for a little bit longer,
the attorney general of the state knocking
out the Republican governor. This is Kentucky.
This is not a blue or a purple state. It was
a tiny margin, just about 5,000 votes. That's
under 0.5% of the vote. But this is just a
brutal loss, not just for Kentucky Republicans,
but also for Trump because of what this race
represents. Now, the immediate question after
these results came in last night was if the
Republican Kentucky governor lost, then maybe
Senate majority leader, Mitch McConnell, Republican
Senator from Kentucky could also lose in Kentucky
in 2020.
It's hard to say. It's a very different race.
McConnell is not as unpopular as Bevin had
become over the last few months. Although
McConnell was not particularly popular. Uh,
and there is actually a more of a history
in Kentucky if you go back, um, of having
democratic governors and there is not a similar,
uh, likewise history of having democratic
senators. So we'll see. Either way, McConnell
is going to have to run a campaign, right?
He's going to have to run a real race against
Amy McGrath who's challenging him. He's not
going to be able to just ignore the threat
from, that's a great race to work on. By the
way, if you live in Kentucky or even if you
don't, eventually, I'm sure there will be
phone banking opportunities. So that's Kentucky.
Let's go from Kentucky to Virginia. In Virginia,
Democrats have taken over control of both
the Virginia state house and the Virginia
state Senate.
They now are going to control the entire state
legislature. They already have a democratic
governor and Virginia is looking more and
more like a blue state. Democrats have been
out of power for 20 years in the Virginia
House of delegates, and they swept yesterday's
election. So in Virginia, democratic governor,
Ralph Northam, democratic house and democratic
Senate incoming and Virginia has been a sort
of, it's interesting what's happened in Virginia.
It's kind of sad actually. They've been held
back at the state level from adopting a lot
of the policies that other solidly blue States
have adopted that could now change with Democrats
taking over total control in Virginia. So
that's a very good sign for Democrats. Here's
another one, Democrats have taken over control
of Mike Pence, his hometown for the first
time in almost four decades now. It's true
Columbus, Indiana, which most of you have
never heard of.
It's not a huge player on the national political
stage. I agree with you. But in terms of the
Trumpist element to this, Mike Pence is Donald
Trump's vice president. His hometown has voted
for Democrats to take over control of the
city council, electing for Democrats to the
city council council taking control for the
first time there in 38 years. Even when you
look at some of the races that Democrats lost
last night, it still doesn't look good for
Republicans. And I'll give you a really interesting
example out of Minnesota, which is the governor's
race there. When you look at the results out
of, I'm sorry, out of a a Mississippi, not
Minnesota. When you look at the Mississippi
results from yesterday, you see that the Republican
incumbent Lieutenant governor Tate Reeves,
won defeating the democratic challenger Jim
hood. Okay? It's Mississippi and a Republican
one. But what does this really tell us?
Well, what it tells us is this is one of the
reddest States in the country. Trump won it
by 17 points in 2016 over Hillary in the 2015
gubernatorial election in Mississippi, the
Republican won by 34 points and last night
the Republican, only one by six turnout was
up more than 70% overall, but Republican turnout
was down by 6% in this race. That is terrible
news for Republicans heading into 2020 and
later on in the show, we're going to get into
some of the battleground States. How much
does national polling matter? We're going
to start getting into the internals of a lot
of this stuff, but if you want, I mean, listen,
the Kentucky result from last night is great.
The Virginia results from last night are great,
but if you want to see a drastic change from
years past at a major red flag for Republicans,
it's that Mississippi, one of the reddest
States in the country, which they often win
in the gubernatorial races by more than 30
points.
They only won by six with voter turnout disproportionately
up, not from Republicans, but from Democrats
and from independence. Terrible news from
Republicans heading into 2020 we'll talk about
2020 a little bit more. If I missed, I obviously
didn't get to everything that happened yesterday,
but if there are races that you think are
important lenses through which we should be
looking to 2020 that I didn't talk about today,
get in touch and I will continue to cover
the results on tomorrow's program.